um
go like you were saying you're like a
teacher on your and i think that
you're a very smart dude um i feel like
you've navigated
uh you know fame in in a way that not a
lot of people in your position have i
feel like
you know you've had your little like
youtube spats with people and [ __ ] but i
feel like as far as just like being
overly
goofy and and like you know i feel like
you have never really been the butt of
many jokes
a lot of times people who come up the
way you came up it's like easy
yeah i feel like jake paul these guys
are like they're kind of like
you know they're goofy you know what i'm
saying i feel like you've navigated the
fame
uh in in a very mature way man and um
you continue to kind of level up like
what is kind of like your secret sauce
as to
how to stay level-headed like that and
you know to kind of stay out the way as
much as possible
what you mean like which is i mean
obviously you've had public
relationships and [ __ ] i just mean like
i don't think i ever he really hear you
getting into any [ __ ]
yeah like most people there's always
some antics or some like
some drug [ __ ] or like whatever it is i
feel like you're a very level-headed
smart dude
yeah man i was valedictorian in high
school i don't know if anybody ever told
you that
valedictorian i think you might have
told us that in the last interview we
did
i did you might have i don't tell nobody
so you were the valedictorian i was
valedictorian in high school
yeah so i'm very smart dude you know
i don't i'm cool with everybody
everybody that meet me if
if a [ __ ] beefing with me it's because
he haven't actually met me
you know what i mean like i'm cool as
hell i'll just be chilling you know what
i mean so it's like
for me to have for a [ __ ] to have
problems with me they're reaching
so it's like you know i rarely get into
[ __ ] like that
and you've never really had like any
like you're not like a big drug dude
like anything like you never like had
the pill issues you know i feel like
everybody in l.a was [ __ ]
zombies in like 2018 for a while there
well i'm scared of that [ __ ] i just got
started smoking weed
damn near barely barely by early
yeah it's crazy man the weed is a
gateway drug so i'm trying to are we
sure about that
yeah that's that's i mean that's what
they told you in the 80s i don't know
you think weed's a gateway drug
i think it is are you afraid you're
going to start [ __ ] shooting heroin
bro it's weird but i'm saying i swear no
weird [ __ ]
like [ __ ] just been coming at me like
i've been hearing
everybody i've been around been talking
about mushrooms and [ __ ] well mushroom's
not a drug either you could do mushrooms
no i can't don't tell me that no no
mushrooms is not uh tell me that because
then if i start
no no no no this [ __ ] is gonna be your
fault nah but it's not bad mushrooms is
a uh
it's a spiritual thing it's like a like
it's almost like
therapy now like mushrooms aren't like
so what's gonna happen if i eat that
[ __ ] well first of all you should be in
a place where you're comfortable
that's what [ __ ] keep telling me you
should be around some people that you
[ __ ] with
exactly and it's not addicting
so it's not like it's not huge or you
eat mushrooms i have before
it's not uh something that um you uh you
need to worry about like
oh man i'm doing drugs now no it's not
that bro it's it's probably less of a
drug than weed is
really yeah you go on a deep trip
and you might figure some [ __ ] out about
yourself man and then you come back on
the other side and this would go
cool mike tyson uh
is a a very big proponent of this [ __ ]
doesn't sound
real though like it sounds like a
fantasy or something well
you know they say that it unlocks parts
of your brain and it kind of you know
it's almost like uh it it just makes you
they call it like you know an ego killer
most
most um psychedelics are supposed to
kind of
kill your ego right so maybe maybe
there's something going on in your life
or there's something you can't get over
that you might not even remember or it
might even like
be a subconscious thing that's like on
you and then you
you tap in and you kind of work [ __ ] out
when you're uh so you're saying it helps
yeah a lot of people man whether it's
mushrooms or dmt
or ayahuasca that [ __ ] like
i've had people like you know i got a
good friend of mine
who was a coke addict alcoholic
[ __ ] womanizer he did ayahuasca which
is
similar it's much more intense it's like
a tea that you drink
and uh he wouldn't did it with a shaman
and came out on the other side and
hasn't touched a drug hasn't gambled
hasn't done nothing
he's like dude it was like 30 years
worth of therapy
in like six hours now that's different
than mushrooms but
i think the idea is kind of the same
there's levels to the psychedelic thing
but mushrooms you should try them
for sure if you want i get you a
mushroom chocolate chocolate bar
chocolate bar put you on i'm gonna just
smoke weed for a little bit
yeah just take take take a little eat
the mushrooms to the face man and just
you know
call off call off for six people like
you it's people like you
see that's but that ain't got nothing to
do with weed being a gateway drug
mushroom's not a drug though it
literally comes from the earth you just
eat it
where do we come from the earth exactly
but jesus said it's a drug
yeah i said i said it's more of a dr i
think it's more of a drug than mushrooms
i don't know lorac what do you think
similar
so you feel like mushrooms helped you
how how did they help you
this is crazy to me bro
i guess understand parts of yourself
that you don't you can't normally access
what the [ __ ] this is some crazy [ __ ]
though it makes you feel small
it makes you realize how small you
really are you feel connected to the
world
yeah you should try it man i bought i
listen i got a guy who got the mushroom
chocolate bars
oh billy's actually yeah he bought like
seven
bars yesterday yeah i got you bro no but
you gotta you know you gotta just you
know be with the be at your house or go
out to like joshua trees so you eat a
chocolate bar and that [ __ ] get you
you shouldn't eat the whole chocolate
bar you should eat about half
maybe three pieces and then just relax
bro and just let it let it let it work
its way into your head man
yeah that just sounds scary i'm gonna
buy this man
i'm not ready for it no we can't have a
chocolate bar i'm not ready for it i'm
cool man i'ma just go it might change
your life
smoke my little prerogative hey there
you go smoke your pre-rolls man